20 years of civil war you know there's
nothing simple about it this is bigger
now
Chemical Weapons fallen into terrorist
hands they could be anywhere we need to
move fast
what do you suggest my business trip
let's talk I need your help because of
this poison my people have known
something worse than war post racket if
you stay we can help you but if you stay
your fight you going are too
the invaders of my country has no regard
for human life
we live like this every day any further
complications are more at war
but breaking through now we need a new
instruction point first
save yourself daughter join us elite
soldiers you trained killers but we are
all killers here no how about you
captain you'll let them die chemical
weapons are now in the wild fix it
why do we do a Politis huh you throw the
line no stop wherever you need it the
arm switch we're all just pawns in this
you speak for yourself this is crazy
crazy way
the rules of engagement have changed if
you can't identify the target you are
the target purchase digital you get the
xrk weapons pack
you